[Music]
the world
is in shock as a group of terrorists has
taken control of large areas of syria
and iran the world can be a cruel and
dangerous place
remember even if you're afraid
be strong
your loving mother fatima
[Music]
did your mother ever tell you the story
of the lady
of heaven she was very special
daughter to the prophet muhammad
my time is near and after with my lovely
fatima
you will face many trials
with my father no longer here to lead us
evil is with those who will extinguish
the light of truth
you're gonna let a woman tell us what to
do
god will judge all of you
this world has become a breeding ground
of islands
shadow will be cast across many
generations to come
it's said some people are so full of
faith
biggest strengths to everyone around
them
the greatest thing in this life
and the hereafter is the spreading of
peace in the world
lady fatima's goodness inspired people
to stand up no matter what the cost
her legacy lives on
[Music]
you